now prince harry has appeared
accompanied by his wife megan at the
united nations in new york the duke of
sussex delivered a speech warning about
the dangers of ignoring climate change
and the impact it's already having on
vulnerable communities but the
publication of a new book threatens to
distract from the couple's message
revenge written by the investigative
journalist tom bower claims to be an
insider account on the divisions between
the sussexes and the royal family now
this report from our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills does contain some flash
photography
before he'd even had a chance to speak
at the united nations there were
questions prince harry are you worried
that tom bauer's new book is going to
widen your rift with the royal family
but another book about the breaker
wasn't going to put harry off his stride
being asked to speak for nelson mandela
day was a huge privilege
the few weaponizing lies and
disinformation at the expense of the
many and from the horrific war in
ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
the cause of mandela's life as we sit
here today our world is on fire again
and this crisis will only grow worse
unless
our leaders
lead
it has surprised some that he was even
asked to speak on such prestigious stage
after everything that's happened with
the royal family
[Music]
but his links with the mandelas run deep
in 2015 in johannesburg he met his widow
gracia michelle
a visit where he was also shown this
photo of princess diana a picture he
told the un he still has on his wall
ender laker mandela his granddaughter
explained to me why the family feel that
connection to harry
this iconic families you know the the
royal family my family is what i would
consider as a tribe so to speak
and it's very difficult to have to find
your own voice
in a tribe like that one thing i learned
from both my grandparents that you need
to be true and honor your voice and
that's what exactly what princeton is
doing he's honoring his voice is it time
for a person of color to be the next
prime minister of britain
he wouldn't have been asked questions
like that when he was a working royal in
the uk but with a new book about the
split out this week and harry's own book
still to come the interest in their old
life isn't dying down no matter how much
they are trying to move on rihanna mills
sky news
now the parents of a three-year-old boy
who died in a tractor crash on a farm in
berry have paid tribute to their son
alby speakman died before he could be
taken to hospital after the incident in
the tottington area the tragedy has once
again raised concerns about the safety
of farming which has the worst record of
any industry in the country disguised
insane rasheed reports
the right brill way good job
a little sunshine boy who just wanted
everyone to be happy
words from albie speakman's mum after a
tragic incident which took this boy's
life on saturday
the three-year-old was involved in a
collision with a tractor at his dad's
home in bury the latest casualty on a
farm
but this kind of tragedy is no stranger
to farmlands across britain
whether it's workers or family members
over the last five years at least 161
people have died on farms and the most
common cause is when someone is struck
by a moving vehicle and so the scale of
fatalities and accidents makes this
workplace the deadliest in the country
brian has first-hand experience of the
dangers in this industry earlier this
year he was sentenced for killing his
four-year-old nephew harry lee
i put him on the machine
as i had done in the past
and we drove out the yard on the lane
and into the field
and then you know i turned around in a
gun and he was under the wheel and
that's what happened like i really saw
so quick
how much do you miss not having him now
on the farm with you lords
every day every day i miss him
he saw that i have to live with what
will happen to him
and
i'll do anything to bring him back
and it isn't just toddlers at risk data
released by the health and safety
regulator shows of the 25 deaths on
farms in the last year all but one were
adults farmers are pushed for time
they're trying to do a little bit more
than they should do they're dependent on
the weather they're dependent on labor
they're dependent on finances so often
they push themselves that little bit too
far don't necessarily think ahead and
often the worst can happen
despite all of the education farming
continues to have the worst safety
record in the uk indoman rashid sky news
lancashire